the Joe Rogan experience what is it like
when you go to England you take two days
off what is that feeling you sit there
and go like boy everything sure is crisp
does it need to be it's not bad it's not
like I'm Jones and I'm pounding tables
III don't have that kind of relationship
with it but it is kind of like you know
like remember I were a hockey jersey
forever mmm
you know a lot of people were like you
don't want to wear something out to Mike
I'm you know I've been married for like
20 years like I dig in I'm once
something works me I stick with it went
vegan still vegan you know like never
really altered since that happened and
stuff so you know most heart attack
right post heart attack have it righted
the day after the heart attack because
my kid made me my kid was like she'd
been vegan for a couple years and she
was like scared she'd never been through
anything real first world kid wonderful
kid but like you have tragedies in life
at [ __ ] like that we you know we do
getting regular blood worked on I just
went and saw my doctor I'm what is it
two months ago hmm
dr. Leighton Heim and did the stress
test where you know you're on the
treadmill and you grow up and stuff and
then they take all the blood and he was
like whatever you're doing keep doing
it's amazing he said I can see your
heart because they take procedure all
right he's like I know where the heart
attack was so I know exactly where to
look he's going if I didn't know where
to look you would never tell he's like
right now there's no lasting damage keep
going so I hiked Runyon every day
nice I'm vegan out like a year and a
half ago because the kid and and haven't
really straight back so I'm all
plant-based and I I'm intermittent
faster I don't eat breakfast anymore I'm
not gonna be like breakfast is
propaganda but it kind of is you don't
really need to eat that early a
particular you know what that's untrue
thin people maybe do guy my size
certainly didn't need to be eatin
breakfast could have skipped it I do the
same take 16 hours off
that's the you be wait to break the fast
do you pick a time or is is deep enough
days you can go just eight and 16 you
know let's just do it
based on and what's as soon as you eight
then generally speaking it depends but
I've gone I've gone as late as like 1:00
2:00 in the afternoon yeah that's why I
try to make it so new
the earliest and like by two I'm ready
I'm ravenous yeah yeah I think it's
totally doable it's it's not your body
gets really used to it to what I
generally do is I get up in the morning
I'll have a cup of coffee and then I
work out and either I run or I do yoga
or do something whatever I do is pretty
intense and and then I do podcasts
generally around noon that's when I
start the day and so I've already been
up for hours and hours
and sometimes I don't even eat until
after the podcast sometimes they'll eat
it like three have you gone days where
you don't eat at all no I've done that I
burn off too many calories I thought you
also workout it yeah I just have the
hiking stuff but I love days where I can
totally skip all the way down because
the body is still feeding off of like
yes Stewart energy and stuff like yeah
but but I'm also you know I'm on WWE
ambassador so that made like my reduced
eating made like staying on points like
insanely he's right
[Applause]